Trascrizione: Marco Caresia
Revisore: Federico Sangati
La voce è uno strumento emotivo.
Tutte le voci sono uno strumento emotivo
e di solito quando pensiamo alla voce
tendiamo a credere che si tratti
di qualcosa di esterno.
Abbiamo i cantanti: cantano.
Hanno una voce, il LORO è
uno strumento emotivo.
No, il TUO è uno strumento emotivo.
Perché la voce ce l'abbiamo tutti
e comunichiamo attraverso la voce.
È un po' come una seconda pelle,
è un punto di contatto tra noi
e le altre persone.
Ma la voce, a differenza della pelle,
racconta moltissime cose.
Racconta molte più cose di quante
noi vorremmo raccontare.
Perché tante memorie noi le abbiamo perse,
ma la voce no.
Sì, la voce si ricorda
di un sacco di cose;
un sacco di cose dell'infanzia,
della crescita.
Ne sentiamo tante di voci
durante il giorno.
Almeno un centinaio di voci
sicuramente le sentiamo!
E ci poniamo il problema o, se non altro,
pensiamo che potrebbe essere
uno strumento d'analisi?
La voce della persona che ci sta parlando
contiene, in qualche modo, la sua storia.
Contiene delle informazioni
su quella persona stessa.
Per noi è semplicemente
una suoneria organica dell'entità
che ci sta di fronte però invece è
qualcosa di un pochino più profondo.
Sentiamo voci rotte, voci graffiate,
voci in transito tra un'età e un'altra,
voci in transito
da un'identità e un'altra.
Sentiamo tantissime voci.
Mi affascina moltissimo questa cosa.
La voce è la finestra attraverso la quale
io guardo l'emotività, l'interiorità
dell'essere umano.
Io sono un vocal coach:
mi occupo di voce.
Vocal coach potrebbe essere
tranquillamente un modo creativo per dire
che non sapevo come chiamare il mio lavoro
però un po' più praticamente, anzi,
un po' più metafisicamente
(che mi piace di più)
vocal coach è un po' come aiutare
le persone ad addomesticare
la propria voce.
Addomesticare come faceva la volpe
col piccolo Principe:
creare dei legami profondi.
OK. Questo è quello
che mi piace pensare di fare.
Vi racconto anche un pochino
come ci sono arrivato a questo.
Da bambino avevo un sogno: cantare.
C'era un piccolo ostacolino:
ero molto timido.
Talmente tanto timido che,
quando mi chiedevano
che cosa volevo fare, dicevo
che volevo fare lo scienziato.
Più o meno, era il mio modo per coprirmi.
Ero terrorizzato dalla paura.
Ero terrorizzato dalla paura di sbagliare,
o meglio dalla paura di essere sbagliato,
o meglio ancora, dalla paura che gli altri
potessero dirmi che ero sbagliato.
Sentirmi diverso.
E poi si cresce arrivano i 16 anni,
e a 16 anni non migliora la situazione,
lo sappiamo benissimo, qualcuno di voi
magari gli ha passati da un pochino
più di tempo però comunque un po'
ci ricordiamo come sono.
A 16 anni c’è sempre quella cosa
che non va, qualcosa c' è sempre:
sono un po' grassoccio, un po' stupidino,
un po' troppo intelligente,
- probabilmente per qualcuno -
capelli messi male, sono brutto, sono gay
(non capiterà a tutti ma,
credetemi, capita).
Ma, a prescindere da questo, a 16 anni
a me è successa una cosa bellissima:
ho conosciuto il teatro.
Ho iniziato a fare teatro
e a sperimentare con la mia voce
a quell'età, un'età in cui o cerchi
un rifugio o esplodi.
Ho trovato un rifugio,
un momento giustificato in cui,
in qualche modo, potevo essere diverso,
in cui, in qualche modo,
potevo essere sbagliato.
Dopo, ovviamente, diversi anni,
facendo un pochino
il punto della situazione mi sono
reso conto di una cosa:
lì, in quel momento,
non ero consapevole di quello
che stavo facendo e la paura
che avevo rispetto all'errore
mi bloccava anche nell'atto creativo.
Non riuscivo ad avere un humus fertile
per la mia creatività,
perché la paura ti tiene fermo
e non ti fa agire.
Però la vita mi ha preso per mano
e attraverso diversi percorsi
dal teatro alla voce, appunto,
ma fino alla psicoterapia
e fino alla filosofia buddista,
la vita mi ha veramente condotto oltre,
da un'altra parte e mi ha in qualche modo
rivoluzionato come essere umano.
Allora ho detto: va bene, questo è
il mio lavoro, questa è la mia missione:
aiutare le persone
nei propri processi di rivoluzione.
Passerò attraverso la voce,
passerò attraverso il corpo,
ma passerò attraverso
un'altra miriade di cose.
OK, aiutare le persone
nella propria rivoluzione.
Bello, suona bene, se non altro.
Ma come si fa?
Cioè, a livello pratico, poi, alla fine?
Perché, stringi stringi, devi riuscire
a creare un metodo, ad avere un modo,
per riuscire a entrare in contatto
con le persone, altrimenti, sta lì.
Ho pensato una cosa: quelli che stanno
molto ad Oriente dicono
che la tecnica va ripetuta
e poi interiorizzata piano piano.
Quelli che stanno molto
ad Occidente dicono: training.
Training ci piace. Training è facile.
‘Strigne’, quindi va benissimo.
Training: focalizzare
la dinamica di blocco,
creare una controtendenza,
sistematizzarla.
Detto così... proviamo a renderlo pratico!
Un esempio: stiamo in ascolto
del nostro corpo, ogni tanto?
Anche in questo momento, ci stiamo
in ascolto del nostro corpo?
Perché il nostro corpo ci manda
dei segnali, ce le dice delle cosine.
OK, facciamo un piccolo esperimentino.
Vi faccio provare due cose
che normalmente farei in classe.
Siete una classe un po' più numerosa,
immagino che non siate
tutti quanti cantanti,
per cui farò fare
delle cose semplici semplici.
OK. Sedetevi sul bordo della sedia.
Ora vi faccio muovere. Bene.
Mettete la colonna dritta. Sshh!
Attenzione! Disciplina, bravi!
Mi sento in aula. OK.
Tenete la schiena dritta. Ora,
in questa posizione seduti
sul bordo della sedia,
rilassate le vostre spalle,
rilassate i glutei e rilassate la pancia.
Ahh. Non lo fate mai, non lo facciamo mai.
Ma perché di base è un retaggio animale,
siamo sempre pronti all’agguato
da dietro di qualche animale.
OK, voglio tranquillizzarvi,
oggi una lince non vi attaccherà.
(Risate.)
Quindi, rilassiamo queste tre parti:
glutei, pancia e spalle
e ora sbadigliamo!
(Sbadiglia) Via, via, sbadigliate!
(Sbadiglia)
OK. Ora proviamo,
prendendo l'aria dal naso,
a gonfiare la pancia come nello sbadiglio.
(Gonfia la pancia)
Funziona? Voglio sentire la vostra voce.
Funziona? Pubblico: “Sì”. OK.
Questa è la respirazione diaframmatica:
ci fanno una testa così normalmente
con la respirazione diaframmatica,
soprattutto a teatro.
Invece è semplicissima.
Quando dormiamo la facciamo.
Il punto è questo:
il nostro corpo risponde
quando non mettiamo un controllo.
Questo è abbastanza
importante da ricordare,
però questa roba qua
ve la potete riprovare un pochino,
soprattutto quando siete in ansia,
magari prima di un talk.
È abbastanza importante saper respirare,
quindi sfruttiamola!
Altra piccola cosina:
mi fate un suono facile: “A”.
Pubblico: “A”.
OK. Qualcuno avrà sentito
un po' una strettoia,
come se ci fosse un po' il nodo alla gola,
il famoso nodo alla gola:
ok, è tutto normale.
Abbiamo delle strutture di protezione
nel corpo che vanno in tensione
ogni volta che il corpo ha paura.
Per cui, se hai paura di sentirti
un idiota facendo “A”,
il corpo si è chiuso. Tutto a posto.
Ora, proviamo ad aprirlo? “Haha.”
Pubblico: “Haha.”
Molto bene. A prescindere dal fatto
che la risata sia di per sé
una cosa simpatica
(potete ritornare a sedervi
nelle posizioni che per voi sono
più consone e comode),
a prescindere dal fatto
che la risata porti apertura
nella vita, anche sociale, in questo caso,
semplicemente, a livello biomeccanico,
sposta, apre delle zone che normalmente
sono di protezione e mandare
in chiusura la nostra voce.
Questo è solamente un assaggino
di quello che faccio.
Ma il nostro corpo parla, ci dice che
il nostro corpo, la nostra esistenza,
la nostra vita è stata
strutturata dalla paura.
È stata strutturata dalla paura
dell'errore e, allora,
visto che ce lo sta dicendo,
cerchiamo di reagire.
Come agisca la paura,
se la paura tiene fermi la controtendenza,
l'azione, e allora agisci.
Azioni piccole:
respira profondamente, ogni giorno;
ridi sonoramente, ogni giorno.
Fai tutto ciò che hai voglia di fare
nel rispetto del vicino, ovviamente,
ma veramente datti la possibilità
di fare ogni qual volta pensi
di non doverlo fare perché hai paura
che quella roba sia sbagliata,
sperimenta, prova!
Non proviamo, non sperimentiamo più,
non abbiamo più,
non ci diamo più questa possibilità.
Fin da quando siamo bambini,
sperimentiamo, sperimentiamo,
arriviamo ad una certa altezza
e poi si smette. OK?
Perché il bambino può imparare
e quindi può sbagliare; l'adulto no.
I bambini imparano, gli adulti fanno.
Noi facciamo soltanto quello
che sappiamo già fare. Però basta.
Possiamo andare un pochino oltre:
vogliamo essere veramente creativi?
Allora il nostro potere creativo risiede
in ciò che noi possiamo fare
nel nostro potenziale,
non nel recintino di quello
che sappiamo fare.
Abbattiamo i limiti alla paura!
Usciamo fuori da questo recintino!
Fai tutto ciò che hai voglia di fare.
Sbaglia! Hai il diritto di sbagliare.
Quando siamo bambini, la caduta è
uno step d'apprendimento. Bene.
Si dice che un essere umano
per potersi muovere,
per poter avanzare e fare un passo
abbia necessità di allontanarsi
dal suo centro, di perdere l'equilibrio,
di perdersi, in qualche modo.
Ora, se la caduta è uno step
d'apprendimento, a noi la scelta
se stare fermi, o errare. Grazie.
(Applausi)